Why is DC Comics a sin?
Oh, I can't answer that one.
You can't even explain a little bit?
No. All I can say is that if it makes you
laugh, then why does it matter? And if it
doesn't make you laugh, you're probably part
of the reason the other people are laughing.
Where is that f*cking wizard music video you've
been promising us for over two months?
Okay, this one's my bad, alright? I got excited
and I started teasing early, before I realized,
like, post production and color correcting
and effects and stuff in the real world can
actually take some time. So that's my fault.
All on me.
So it is coming?
Yeah, yeah. It'll be here next month. July
for sure. You can book it, write it down.
Will you tell us what it's about?
I can't tell you that. I mean, all I can say
is that it's based on something said in one
of our previous videos, and it's one of the
most pointless things we've ever made.
Awesome. Is it at least going to be worth
all the hype? All the build-up?
Oh, no. Certainly not. Like, that would be
impossible at this point. It looks good, because
we hired a pro to shoot it, but nobody asked
for this. Nobody would ever have asked for
this.
Are you and Honest Trailers connected?
No. Only in mutual admiration, and we're both
channels that make fun of movies. And we both
like boobs.
Your channel is about to pass 500,000 subscribers.
How the hell did you get so many subs so quickly?
That's it? That's all you got?
Well, how the f*ck do I know how it happened?
You think if I knew how it happened I wouldn't
have done it sooner? I mean, it happened,
and yeah, I'm pretty happy about it. I'm gonna
run with that sh*t. But f*ck if I know how
it happened.
500,000. That's really a lot of people. Like,
you have half a million fans.
Eh, they clicked a button.
That button click represents more than just
a click, that's their endorsement of you,
they're saying, "We like you, we want to see
more of your content."
Don't you want to show them you appreciate
that? Don't you want to let them know that
without them you'd be nothing?
The fans?
Don't you want to say, "Thank you?"
You know I'm not really a "thank you" kind
of guy.
They know that, dude. That's exactly why it
will matter if you actually said it.
Thank you.
Well, that was memorable.
Well, don't ask a cat to bark and then be
upset when it meows. Think fast.